hello everyone and welcome
to today's webinar how molecular combing
technology is transforming genomic
research
through visualizing dna at the single
molecular level i'm susie valdez of lab
roots and i will be your moderator for
today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by genomic
vision to learn more
visit them at genomicvision.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting
as many questions as you have during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation i'd
now like to welcome our speaker
mark lynch the director of global
commercial and marketing
at genomic vision mark welcome you may
now begin
your presentation
thank you for the introduction good day
my name is mark lynch
i'm the director of global commercial
and marketing at genomic vision
and welcome to our first genomic vision
webinar
summer series in this webinar today i'm
going to walk you through
what molecular combing is what molecular
coming can do for your research
in terms of being able to provide
visualization
of dna structure at high resolution
and quantification of structural changes
in dna molecules
we will also provide an overview of the
applications
that molecular coming can enable in
cancer
in genetic disease research in gene
discovery and engineering
and in drug development our aim is at
the end of the webinar that you will
learn about how our proprietary
technology can be used and what you
think
it can do for your research and
laboratory workflows
this is the first part of a four-part
webinar series
as you can see on this slide after
today's webinar we have three subsequent
sessions
today i'm going to walk you through how
molecular combing technology
is transforming genetic research through
visualization of dna
at the single molecule level
but in sessions two and in sessions
three you're going to learn a lot more
about the applications
in cancer biology and complex diseases
and we'll illustrate in those sessions
how to quantify structural and copy
number variants
and review how molecular combing can
provide a better understanding of
replication kinetics
in cancer biology and in sessions two
and three in june 10 and june 24
respectively
we will focus on genetic disease
research and our cancer research
the last in our program on july 1st
focuses on how molecular combing can be
used as a quality control method
in therapeutic genome editing
applications and bioproduction
overall we at genomic vision want to
familiarize you with molecular combing
and how this technology can be used
alongside
techniques such as next generation
sequencing
for the characterization of structural
variants
for dna damage and for replication
analysis
and we also want to convey you over the
next four weeks
how this method how molecular combing
supersedes technologies
such as southern blots for the analysis
of structural repeat units
but back to today's webinar in today's
webinar we're going to introduce to you
what molecular coming is to enable you
to understand
what the technology of genomic vision is
all about
and enable you to think about how this
technology can be used alongside
applications
such as long reads next generation
sequencing and how it can be used to
overcome the obstacles of short reads
next generation sequencing
droplet digital pcr real-time pcr
and southern blots in addition to that
the second part of today's presentation
is all about familiarizing you with the
workflow solutions
from genomic vision you're going to hear
about these fiber toolkits that's one of
our brand names
fiber is our primary focus and it's all
about stretching out dna
to visualize and quantify the structural
variants of the fibers of dna
we're going to introduce our technology
for for long read dna extraction
fiber prep stretching dna fiber comb
visualizing dna fragments fiber vision
and the analysis fibre studio and that's
going to take place in the second part
of the presentation
and lastly in the webinar today we're
going to provide an overview
of some of the interesting applications
that you're going to see in more detail
in the next three weeks the aim is to
get those neurons flowing
so that you can understand how our
exciting molecular combing technology
can be used in your own laboratories
today
we will provide a preview of how that
technology can be used for dna
replication
in say the study of cancer biology the
analysis of structural repeat regions
in diseases such as fshd and provide a
little bit of insight into how other
applications
here at genomic vision that we have in
the pipeline including the analysis of
telomere
telomere lens and telomere
characterization
for those unfamiliar with our company a
few words on genomic vision
we started out in 2004 as a spin out
from the pasteur institute in france
and we spent many years focused on the
development of molecular coming
for both research use and for diagnostic
ceibd use
more recently we've partnered with large
institutes and consortium globally
to ensure our molecular combing
technology can be leveraged
for a broader appeal across multiple
applications
in recent years we've focused on the
productization of our portfolio
ensuring that we've got a product that's
fully developed and accepted by our
customers
and now we're focused on broader
expansion of molecular combing in the
marketplace
which is why we're presenting to you
today
so why molecular coming what is
molecular coming all about
i'd like to provide you in this section
with an introduction
to molecular coming
the principle of molecular combing is
essentially that we are stretching out
dna
to resolve it at high resolution and
characterize
in other words looking at the physical
structure of the dna
and the quantification the molecular
biology of that dna
you can see on the right hand side of
the slide an example of stretched dna
that is not fluorescently labeled what i
want you to achieve at the end of this
introduction is an
understanding of how we're able to get
both high resolution
visual images of the structure of the
fibers of dna
as well as the molecular readout and the
quantification of those
molecular coming is a proprietary method
to extract
capture and extend fibers of dna to
enable high resolution imaging
analysis and quantification of the
characteristics of single dna molecules
the technique enables the quantitative
features
of dna such as structural variants and
replication tracks
to be analyzed visually and at the
molecular level in parallel
molecular combing with our fibre-based
technology
uses constant stretching factors to
provide visualization
and quantification of single molecule
dna that can be used to quantify the
length
and distances in genomic features
we at genomic vision have revolutionized
molecular combing
to visualize and quantitate the
structural features of dna
for a range of applications in single
molecule dna analysis
so while so far we've explained a little
bit about the principle of molecular
combing
what we haven't explained is what this
means to you
in this slide i'd like to provide an
overview of molecular combing and
something called genetic morse code
on the left hand side of the slide is a
schematic
of what molecular combing means
to a researcher in the lab you can start
with blood
cells or tissues and our application
requires just 5 ml of blood or 10 000
cells these samples are then extracted
using a proprietary kit from genomic
vision that
extracts high molecular weight dna
once that dna extraction is performed
off-the-shelf cover slips
can be used from genomic vision to comb
the dna
and this creates a stretch of dna
on these cover slips that you can show
that you can see
on the left hand side of the slide
this creates a highly dense and
stretched matrix
of fibers that can then be tagged with
specific
probes we'll talk about more on those in
a moment
to enable visualization at high
resolution
to determine both the image of the
specific region of interest
and the quantification
on the left hand side for the output of
images and statistics
you can also see that using these combed
dna molecules
you can see the fluorescence that you
achieve using
probe based detection and the difference
in fluorescence and spatial position
which we'll talk about in a moment
enables you to understand structural
variants like deletions
or like copy number variants furthermore
it can be used to understand replication
parameters
such as the termination sites and the
origin sites
and the changes in those replication
parameters
so already why is this important to you
because what you're able to get with
molecular combing
is a technology that enables you to take
sample
stretch the dna out of that that sample
perform the fluorescence tagging and
look at the physical features of those
individual fibers of dna
as well as the quantification features
all of that without any pcr
amplification bias meaning
that the technology is not subject to
things like
repeat elements within the genome
a little bit more on that includes
something called the genetic
morse code this is shown on the right
hand side of the slide
generic morse code is a probe design
that we've not touched upon so far
but it's a proprietary probe design
that's made up of different colours and
sizes
to recognize a selected region of
interest
genetic morse code is used for the
comprehensive analysis and physical
mapping
of target regions on stretch dna
and because of this you end up with this
stretched dna target and it's
created a specific morse code for a
specific region of interest
so deploying genetic morse code for
example
can be used as a spatial distribution as
well as fluorescence
and can be used to characterize the
genome and on the right hand side of the
slide you can see the recognition
of different motifs of the genetic morse
code or gmc
and you can see in this example for gene
one gene two and gene three
you can see how we can characterize
based on that gmc
per fragment deletion amplification
and insertion events
so molecular combing and gmc or genetic
morse code solutions
offer precise and accurate measurements
along with the visualization of
structural dna
to characterize things like the length
and distance
without any pcr amplification
so a little bit more on the workflow the
technical steps in the workflow in other
words what is our solution
actually doing and you can see on this
slide that it's a six
step process step one is the standard
sample collection of cells blood and
tissues
step two is the extraction of large
molecular weight
dna from those cells blood and tissues
once that extraction is complete we then
perform the probe design and labeling
using
immunofluorescence and then we comb
that dna onto an off-the-shelf coverslip
to stretch out the fragments of dna
we then perform immunostaining using
specific probes and then we perform
an imaging and analysis and you can see
on this schematic that we've gone from a
grayscale image which we showed you
earlier in the presentation to an image
that starts to show you the type of
morse code with the different colors in
green
and in red that you can see pair
fragment of dna
we're going to talk more in the
presentation about how we automate this
process
because six steps is quite a lot of
steps to perform
but we here at genomic vision have got a
workflow solution
to enable you to automate this process
before we get on to that what
applications does molecular combing
enable for you
the applications enabled by molecular
combing help to characterize genomics
across multiple innovative applications
in genetics
cancer research genome engineering and
drug development
and you can see in this dna structure
what we're all about
we're all about taking all these factors
to characterize genomics
at the top left hand side we talk about
genetic background
and with genetic background we're
talking about things like repeat
expansion and contraction
virus cellular integration and the
detection of large rearrangements
and there's an image shown on this slide
that shows you the type of the gmc
genetic morse code that you see both in
the high resolution image
as well as in the analysis to quantify
our technology is also used for cancer
research
for the accurate measurement of dna
replication kinetics
the identification of rearrangements in
predisposing genes
genome assembly and characterization and
again you can see an example of the
images that you get from one of our
systems
to be able to show you the rearrangement
events that take place
live in those specific fragments of dna
other applications enabled by molecular
combing include
genome engineering and novel therapies
and drug development
these particular applications are
generally utilized by the pharmaceutical
markets and customers
and biotech markets genome engineering
and novel therapies include
identification of unexpected
rearrangements during for example crispr
cast 9
and assessing the efficiency of the
editing method
so again using this to make sure that
the efficient insertions
have taken place we also use the
technology for drug development
the identification of various features
of dna replication stress
and drug candidate validation
altogether our application with
molecular combing
is all about characterizing genomics and
the application span
research pharmaceuticals diagnostics
and clinic clinical as well as biotech
so what do you get out of this method
out of this method you're able to get a
very clear image
of specific fragments of dna
that you can see at high resolution i.e
the image and the visualization of the
structural variants
and you get to quantify that
an example of how this is used is in the
molecular combing
for the study of dna replication
the complete characterization of any
replication events
throughout the genome can be established
actually using molecular combing
and in dna replication studies molecular
coming
enables the identification of
replication events
precise measurement of replication speed
and automatic signal detection ought to
identify
inter-origin distance of the symmetry of
the replication fork
our replication combing assay provides
the complete characterization
of any replication events through the
entire genome
and what you will have seen in this
introduction part of this webinar
is how we've gone from a grayscale image
showing stretched fragments of dna
to how we've combed that dna we've
applied
fluorescent probes and spatial probes to
be able to get an image
like as shown on the right hand side of
the slide
where we're able to detect thousands of
replication tracks
using our replication combing assay
of course the field of genomics is
evolving fast and there's a lot of
methods out there
currently there's other applications
such as next generation sequencing
there's other applications such as
optical mapping
these applications enable some of what
we've mentioned in today's presentation
but in actual fact for full genome
characterization
you require molecular coming
the genomic vision solutions that we're
going to go on to talk
about in the next section of this
webinar enable
direct visualization direct detection
they enable being able to characterize
the genome without
any impact from gc rich regions without
any
impact of high repeat regions and we can
look at large variants of up to one
megabase
in this slide it's clear that next
generation sequencing
and optical mapping do not provide the
same level of characterization
that is possible using molecular combing
with genomic vision
and we achieve all of that visualization
detection gc rich region analysis
high repeat region analysis and large
variant analysis
without any technical bias because we do
not perform pcr
and so we do not get any pcr
amplification bias
the take home in this introduction is
that molecular combing enables a better
visualization to bring precise and
refined analysis
so in the first part of this
presentation and we still have two parts
to go
i want you to take away that molecular
combing is a proprietary technique
that extracts dna as long fragments
automates the stretching of dna fibers
to enable automated high quality dna
coming
with high resolution imaging and
quantification
that's the key message what we're going
to talk about next
is the products we're going to talk
about how the workflow
is enabled using our technologies such
as
fiber comb fiber vision and fiber studio
so let's do that let's talk about how we
enable molecular combing
using the technology of fiber toolkits
from genomic vision
so we touched upon much of this workflow
earlier on but earlier on in the
presentation when we looked at this
workflow
it was not clear that it was an
automated based workflow
can see on this slide that there are
actually five steps to the process
the first part is the extraction of long
molecular weight dna from things like
cells
tissues and blood earlier on we spoke
about using five mils of blood or ten
thousand cells
this extraction takes place using a dna
extraction kit
from genomic vision the dna extraction
kit is called fiber prep
so with fiber prep we can perform the
extraction
we also then perform the combing of the
dna in other words the stretching out of
the dna
this combing of dna also takes place
using
off-the-shelf coverslips these
coverslips have undergone extensive
quality control
and are available for purchase from
genomic vision
once the dna extracted from fiber prep
is applied to that slip we then use
fiber comb
to stretch that dna out and the fiber
cone platform
shown in the image below step two is
used to automate the calming process
then we perform immunodetection these
fiber probes can be purchased and
designed by genomic vision
along with if you're interested in
replication assays
to perform the immunodetection of the
specific regions of the genome that
you're
interested in we then use
the fiber vision scanning platform to
automate
the scanning of the fibers and to
automate the fluorescence detection
it's this platform that provides you
with the high resolution image
the last step in the process is of
course to perform the analysis
and the last step of this process uses
the fiber studio
analysis suite to be able to get the
high resolution image
the quantification and the statistical
significance
so our combing workflow provides an
end-to-end workflow
for characterization of events through
the entire
genome at the single molecule level
to provide a little bit more detail on
that and to let you see
how this technology can be incorporated
into your lab
i want to introduce this automated
molecular combing technology in a little
bit more detail
the image on the right hand side of the
slide shows a blue platform
which is the small platform in the
photograph which is the fiber
cone that is the platform that's used to
stretch out the dna
onto our off-the-shelf coverslips
the larger white based platform shown
also on the image
is our fiber vision instrumentation
which enables
walk away scanning and high resolution
imaging
of the long single molecule dna
fragments
you can start with this technology with
as few as 10 thousand cells
or five mils of blood extract the dna
using our genomic vision fiber prep kit
then fiber comb is used to apply the
extracted dna
from the fiber prep onto proprietary
coated
coverslips and automate the process
labeling is prepared using fiber probes
and we apply those fiber probes to
combed dna
in preparation for scanning
scanning is performed at high resolution
and using spatial analysis with fiber
vision or fiber vision s
to generate detailed images of the
characteristics
of the dna fragments of interest at the
single molecule level
as mentioned this is an automated
process
but for those really listening and
understanding you'll hear
that all we're doing essentially is
stretching dna
onto slides and for those that know a
little bit about that technology there
is a method called fiber spreading
that already does exist to do some of
that
but it does not do all of that what
you'll learn
in next three weeks from genomic vision
is that we're able to apply our combing
assays and our combing technologies
with fiber prep fiber vision and fiber
studio
for long fibers with a constant
stretching factor
parallel fibers replication tracks
complexity of signals iod and itd
replication and locus integrity of
signals and standardized analysis
only all of those features are possible
using
genomic vision and using molecular
combing
so in summary for the second of three
parts of this webinar
is that our workflow-based approaches to
molecular combing allow extraction of
long fragments of dna
automated stretching and high quality
cover slips
using fiber comb fluorescence
incorporation using fiber probes
and high resolution imaging with fiber
vision and quantification
with fiber studio and you'll learn in
much more detail
in the next three weeks of our summer
webinar program
how all of these work with numerous
different applications
the last part of our presentation in
today's webinar is just an
overview of some of the applications
enabled by molecular combing technology
i do want to provide you with some
examples of how molecular combing can be
used
for example in the understanding of the
replication
pulsing process
so as mentioned earlier on we do have a
replication combing assay
a replication coming assay really can be
used
for understanding the pulsing uh
during replication for firing in cells
this is known as our replication combing
assay
and it incorporates either single or
double nucleotide analogues
such as idu or cidu
that can be detected by fluorescently
labeled fiber probes
to show differences in the pattern of
replication
using this approach we're able to
measure the mechanistic
view of the replication for firing
rather than just the end point
so in this workflow what you're able to
see is that we start with cells and
culture and we label those cells in
culture with ibu
or clivu and after time
we're able to observe the pulsing state
of those cells
as the replication for firing takes
place
and it means that you can then measure
how much
replication is taking place via the
mechanistic
view so it means that we can measure the
events
of replication and the parameters of
replication
and we get an accurate classification of
the replication
tracks our replication combing assay
enables the detection of all different
combinations of firings
and timings of the origins of
replication
and so what you can see in the center
and on the right of the slide
is the formation of different initiation
and termination events pair dna
fragment within the cells you can see
the differences
in the firings and the timings on the
initiation
and on the termination events
our replication combing assay simplifies
things to uncover complex replication
kinetics
that's difficult to reveal in other
methods
and because of this we are able
to use this methodology to understand
things like
fork speed fork symmetry replicating dna
including the total length of dna and
inter-origin
and inter-termination distance
and so what we're able to provide is an
understanding
of replication kinetics and
understanding of replication pulsing
and an understanding of the
characterization of replication events
in cells as you treat them which is very
important
when it comes to understanding diseases
like cancer
and because this characterization of
replication is so important
coming soon we will be working on
precise length distribution using
molecular combing
with our telomere calming assay
we don't want to go into too many
details on this in today's webinar
but needless to say this is also going
to be a semi-automatic detection
of telomere signals and it's going to be
able to
give an outcome of the average telomere
lens
but also the distribution of the lens
and the minimum
and maximum lengths that are enabled in
the same sample
at high resolution of between 0.8 kb
to 300 kb
and it can be used as a model system in
human and mouse
and the schematic that you can see at
the bottom of this slide
is an example of a single dna fiber
using molecular combing
and fiber vision and in red the single
telomere signal
and so we can take telomere
identification by technology such as
next generation sequencing
and understand the measurement the
precise measurement
and distribution of telomere length
using molecular coming
so if you're interested in replication
and you're interested in telomere
this molecular combing based technology
is an application you may want to
consider
for your laboratory
another application that molecular
combing enables
is to get through the repeat regions
within the genome
and so one of the applications is the
detection of
fshd and we use the detection of fshd
based on d4 z4 repeat units
for fshd there is a highly repeat region
and the contraction of that 3.3 kb
repeat unit
from 1 to 10 repeats on 4 q35
the contraction is pathogenic only and
is associated with the qa haplotype
and on the right hand side you can see
that in a healthy individual
you would have between 11 and 100
repeats
but in fshd1 you have less than 10
repeat elements which is 95
of cases and in fshd2 you have between
12 and 16 repeats
and so polymorphic repeat arrays are
homologous
to d4 z4 but they're also found in 2 10
q26 but not pathogenic traditionally
this has been done by southern blot but
we can use molecular combing to provide
greater resolution of this
the same workflow is used as before
the big difference is that rather than
using
other types of fiber probes for example
replication fiber probes
you can use our fiber probe fshd product
which labels 4q35 and 10 through 26
regions of the chromosome
on stretch dna meaning that we provide
all the necessary tools to process a
blood specimen
to detection for assaying d4 z4
highly repeat regions
and in addition to getting the molecular
output
we're also able to characterize in the
example of fshd
locus modifications for screening of
z4 repeat units and so
on the far left hand side of this slide
you're able to get the
resolution comparing 4qa to 10qa
and the resolution comparing 4qb to 10qb
and the variations that exist without
any bias introduced by pcr
so we are offering a solution with
molecular combing
to characterize d4 z4 repeat at 4q35
and 10 through 26 loci
this is a powerful tool to resolve
complex rearrangements that is often
missed by southern blot
the last part of our presentation is
really to convey to you
some of the technology that some of the
techniques
that the technology of molecular combing
enables
such as the visualization of structural
genomic information
such as dna damage replication analysis
analysis of repeat elements within the
genome to really truly characterize
genomics
as mentioned earlier on this is an
introductory webinar to provide an
overview
of genomic vision and of our molecular
combing technology
over the next three webinars you'll
learn how molecular combing can help
your research
in genetic disease research cancer
biology
and gene therapy as well as molecular
coming
acting as a critical tool set in
bioproduction
as a reminder our next webinar is on
june 10 2021
where my colleague will talk about
simplifying complex genetic diseases
by quantifying structural and copy
number variants
the next three weeks will enable you to
learn more about molecular combing
and understand how molecular combing
using
the fiber vision the fiber probes and
the fiber studio
can be used in your laboratory research
and laboratory workflows
with that i thank you very much for your
time and attention today
more information can be found on our
website www.genomicvision.com
with that we'll now pause for question
and answer
thank you mark for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's take a look at our incoming
questions
coming in from our audience already
mark our first question is how does the
molecular information
provided by molecular combining compare
to next generation sequencing or
real-time pcr methods
thanks very much yeah so this is a
common question that we get
and our molecular combing technology
is complementary mostly to
next generation sequencing and real-time
pcr methods
but what you will have seen in the
presentation is that we are able to get
a level of
imaging from the fragments of dna
that is not possible by next generation
sequencing or real-time pcr
so we're really providing an added level
of information
that is not possible by those
complementary techniques
the other factor is that by definition
a lot of the next generation sequencing
applications
and real-time pcr applications rely on
pcr based amplification
and as we mentioned at the start of the
presentation
we don't rely on that we actually don't
do that pcr amplification
we use our fiber probe based technology
as well as the genetic
morse code the gmc to spatially
and fluorescently measure specific
fragments
of the dna and as a consequence of that
we we're not really able to
be subject to some of the repeat element
regions within the genome such as gc
rich regions or
highly repeatable regions like gga ttt
that you would experience by
applications like next generation
sequencing
so in addition to being able to get the
the imaging the high resolution imaging
to see the structure of the dna
physically
you get a molecular level too that is
not compromised
by things like highly repeat regions
within the genome
thank you thank you so much mark
and how many cells are required for
molecular combing applications
yeah um so it kind of depends on the
type of application
that you're using molecular combing for
in this presentation we featured
uh the replication combing assay or rca
and that particular application in that
particular assay
uh requires just 10 000 cells
now some other applications if you're
looking at things like telomere
or if you're looking at um cell line
authentication or cell line production
you'll need a little bit more maybe
between fifty thousand and a hundred
thousand cells
but in those applications generally
people are looking at
uh cultured cells um in replication of
course it's more like primary cells if
you're looking at specific cancer cells
so those 10 000 cell number it is pretty
achievable by most folks
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
our next question i use author and
blotting for studying
fshd how does molecular coming
compared to southern blood blot analysis
yeah that's a that's a great question um
and it's great to see it coming through
now now keep in mind
in subsequent weeks we have sessions
that are specifically focused
on uh the analysis of repeat elements
for example in diseases like
fshd and in fact in next week's webinar
my colleague mario will be going into
that in more detail
but i can provide a brief overview to
help answer that question
of course southern blots have been have
been around for many years
but they're a very laborious process
they're low throughput
they use a lot of reagents and chemicals
to perform that analysis
and it's not entirely visual
in terms of actually visualizing the the
dna
and so as such um i would i would put it
to you that with southern blot you're
getting a lot more quantified with the
molecular coming
you're getting a lot more high
resolution data
a lot more informative data both from a
quantitative perspective
but also by reducing the amount of noise
that you would normally get in southern
blot but
i would encourage you to attend my
colleagues webinar next week to get way
more information on how that comparison
takes place
thank you so much and how is this
technique
compared to fish
yeah it's another good question and it's
a question that we often get asked and
and there's a few different methods
of fish and for those that don't know in
the audience fish is a fluorescence
in situ hybridization and and there's
various different
methods that can be used for example
there's a method called
htq fish um ht2 fish is quite often used
in telomere analysis
but but it doesn't have the ability to
be able to
distinguish uh the different fragments
or different regions within the telomere
uh whereas molecular combing can then
there's also other types of fluorescence
in situ hybridization or fish such as
flow fish um
this would require an expensive facts
instrument fluorescence activated
self-sorter instrument
and really would only really work with
can a specific cell such as
pdmcs our technology of course using
molecular combing it doesn't succumb to
that
we are able to provide an automated
workflow
which is not always possible by fish and
we are able
um to to provide
um the greater resolution and greater
quantification
compared to fish so we use automated uh
scanning scanner which is a microscope
we have cover slips that are pre-made
for example
that have undergone extensive quality
control and that's how the method
um would work it compares to fish
thank you mark we have time for one more
question
how can we stain the dna with the
immunofluorescence
probe and avoid staining the non-coding
regions
yeah it's another good question um and
thank you again for that
um we have again our webinars in coming
weeks that are going to talk
in way more detail actually in our third
webinar series
uh which is in three weeks from now um
my colleague mario will also be going
into detail on
the use of our fiber probes fiber probes
is something that we touched upon in
this introductory presentation
and when we were using when we use
fiber probes you will have saw with the
genetic
morse code that we use fluorescence and
spatial
positioning within the transcripts and
so actually at genomic vision we can
custom design
those probes for your application needs
in other words
meaning that if you have um if you've
got non-coding regions that you want to
avoid
we can design the probes to specifically
avoid
those non-coding regions but again more
information on that in
our third webinar series
mark i want to thank you for your time
today would you like to provide any
closing remarks
to our audience before we go i think i'm
good but thank you very much the only
thing naturally that i want to say is
thank you for everyone for attending
um and please remember this is a taster
of what molecular combing can bring to
your laboratory workflows
in the coming weeks we have our product
management and our scientific account
managers
walk through a lot more detail than what
was in today's presentation
well thank you again mark for your
presentation and for your important
research
and i'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor genomic vision
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go of course i want to thank
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
and remind you that questions we did not
have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event we look forward to seeing you
at the part two of our webinar series on
june 10th
simplify complex genetic disease
by quantifying structural and copy
number variant
until then stay safe and take care
bye-bye everyone